he is britain's best-known oligarch
but roman abramovich's two decades at
chelsea an enviable london property
portfolio had been undone by his links
to russia and to president putin
abramovich's assets and the club that he
transformed frozen his name added to the
list of billionaires sanctioned by
britain it's important that he doesn't
benefit from the club our priority is to
ensure that the club is protected that
the fans are protected and the national
game
it's an extraordinary moment for foreign
policy and for football chelsea will now
have to operate under a special license
that means season ticket holders can go
to games but fans can't buy new tickets
they'll be subject to a transfer ban
blocked from negotiating new contracts
the club can't sell merchandise three
have already suspended their sponsorship
and whilst reasonable travel costs for
players will be covered longer trips
abroad could be difficult
all the fans all over the world are
devastated right now do you think
they've gone too far with this yeah i
think they've like obviously there's a
massive issue in ukraine but him leaving
it's just
feel like
the club's just dying right now the
value of the our club in terms of
achievements quality of players location
uh
i'm not worried
a little set back but we back back
the government would have been making
sure their case was absolutely legally
watertight before sanctioning roman
abramovich it is a big move it means he
faces a uk travel ban and his assets
including chelsea are frozen and that
makes the process of selling this club
much more complicated
the billionaire had already confirmed
that chelsea's being sold the profits he
said will go to victims of the war in
ukraine
it effectively would have to be sold
via the approval of the government or
the government appointing someone to
work alongside the sellers
to ensure that any sale proceeds went
into an account which could not be
accessed by roman abramovich i think it
does call into question uh the the
premier league's approach to
allowing individuals to come in and buy
football clubs without having any form
of
human rights
clauses
six others have also been sanctioned
today among them mr bramovich's former
business partner oleg deripaska an eagle
section whose yacht was seized by the
french last week
but for the man so deeply entwined in
british football lauded even recently by
some of the most high profile players
whose name less than a week ago was a
rallying cry from chelsea fans at
burnley
it is a moment many believed wouldn't
come chelsea's game tonight against
norwich will go ahead what happens next
for the club is much less certain ali
fortescue sky news